i don't know if you guys
know of a
fella by the name of randy savage um but
just take a quick moment pause for the
cause and um
have a quick conversation about men and
um
like guys taking permanent steps to
temporary problems in their lives okay
um this is a guy that i met at a uh
rally
2018-2019
um very nice man his name is randy uh
tillum he went by randy savage on his
youtube channel there's a post here from
family
uh about his um
uh
permanent steps to a temporary problem
in his life you guys can read between
the lines you can go you know read the
family announcement but
guys suffer in silence and um i don't
know why he did what he did
but
very successful had every car he wanted
you know as far as i knew his
personal life was fine
um had a huge audience on youtube like
over 600 000 uh subs put out you know
fun content i didn't watch a ton of it
over the last couple years but i just
remember him being a nice genuine guy on
the rally kind
um very fun to be around and it's just
sad when like a 51 year old guy you know
does something to
you know which is completely permanent
to a temporary problem in his life
obviously i don't know what the problem
was
um i'm gonna try to find out but um
if you know a guy that's going through
some sort of turmoil
divorce some shit's going down in his
business just reach out to them hey man
everything okay you know you want to
have a quick uh you know chop up session
on anything that's going on you need an
ear or anything
just check in you know just just check
in because
um there's probably some signs there
that something's going on in life and
again most guys suffer in silence they
don't say [ __ ] they just they just kind
of like mill on it so
i just wanted to um
you know drop that out there just as a
just as a psa and uh just to pay a
little homage to
you know what i came to know is a real
nice guy in that rally hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you